lunch money time hey how are you did i
just listen to
also the street belt is real the people
by the way the somebody asked like oh so
you didn't dance he did not dance no you
can't dance what are you going to dance
but you're going to dance with your hand
in your pocket no you can't dance he
stood on the side like a weirdo you just
you just kind of sway you just kind of
sway like this with your hand in your
pocket your street belt
look a little like a little frank
sinatra going on like this that's fine
all right go ahead what's up therefore i
couldn't dance because i can't be
dancing by myself
jeff bezos all right jeff bezos ready
yeah
so this i was surprised by this i don't
know if you were surprised by this but
amazon founder jeff bezos tweeted on
sunday that inflation is most hurtful to
the least affluent people in the united
states and criticize president joe biden
for the second time in a week for his
comments on inflation to be fair to jeff
bezos
biden's comments were pretty ridiculous
regardless if you're a democrat or a
conservative what do you think
three things i want to quickly talk
about what first and foremost my biggest
takeaway
the worst nightmare for politicians
is the single greatest entrepreneurs of
our lifetime armed with twitter accounts
and no fear of speaking their mind
and that's what jeff bezos has started
to do
he's based
and he is tweeting
and if i was a politician i would be
very very very nervous
because the second that
you have the greatest entrepreneurs
armed with twitter accounts and speaking
their mind
it changes
all of the conversations the question
question question question
until recently answer jeff bezos wasn't
really using his twitter account is this
because i mean he was using it for pr
things is this because of elon musk
my guess is there's a little bit of a
medic response hey that i used to be the
richest guy now that guy's the richest
guy this guy seems to have all the
people in the palm of his hand on
twitter maybe i want to have some people
in my palm and so maybe i'll start
tweeting a little bit yes that is part
of it i i'm guessing but even more
importantly is i bet you he's had all
these ideas the entire time he just
always approached it as you know michael
jordan hey i'm not a republican i'm not
democrat both sides of the aisle buy
shoes
amazon same thing listen republicans and
democrats they both use the internet to
order things like that but to be fair
inflation is a very like nobody likes
inflation it's not like they're going to
be like oh i'm not going to shop on it
no they're all going to start
encouraging each other now now now the
snowball has started you know but musk
now you have bezos now it's just like
free game anyone that is wealthy or
successful you now can go on the
internet and you can say what you think
and no one's going to judge you
or not know he's going to judge you but
like there won't be the blowback that
there used to be the perception of why
not because now people are like yeah
guess what capitalism might actually
work there's this pendulum that swings
and over the last couple years it's
swung in favor of or towards socialism
government and event intervention all
this nonsense and now people are sitting
there saying damn we just tried that in
a watered down version and my life ain't
going better
i got high inflation this is going wrong
this is going wrong this is going wrong
maybe we need to swing the pendulum back
and now you're going to see all the
capitalists come out of the woodwork and
they're gonna start saying you know what
we need we need people to build
solutions the government does not build
solutions instead what we need is we
need private market uh or private
enterprises to go build solutions to our
problems yeah i agree
it's bad news bears for the government
for inflation
all right ready by the way people are
like pro business pom keep talking pro
business yes yes that is
the whole point of business is to solve
problems this show is called the best
business like
if you don't like business
you are not going to go very far in life
everything is a business how here's a
perfect example remember that pandemic
that everyone was freaking out about how
do you think that the
vaccine actually got created
because a business created it
a business who wanted to make money
created it now you can argue does it
work does it not work is uh it charged
too much does it not charge enough do
they make too much money all that stuff
but at the end of the day a business
created a solution to a problem and
that's how the world works okay next all
right
so
former goldman sachs ceo lloyd blink
fine is that how you say okay he said
that he believes that the economy is at
risk of possibly going into a recession
as the fed continues to raise interest
rates to tackle rising inflation i mean
duh is this not obvious hey lloyd
welcome to the train buddy
i appreciate y'all he's like saying he's
like that kid in school that like finds
out what's no let me i'm actually gonna
defend him for a second here here here's
what i think's probably been going on is
i actually think that folks like this
they have no doubt whatsoever in their
mind they know exactly how the financial
system works they know exactly what was
going to happen it was either unpopular
or not acceptable in their social
circles or in their kind of handler
groups in order to say the things that
uh they're saying now now the tide has
turned again it's this whole idea of
we're going back to business we're going
back to capitalism we're going back to
the thought process where people can
start to say whatever they need to say
or what they want to say and so he's now
just saying probably what he was saying
behind closed doors for the last six to
12 months and so now that it's
acceptable you get these comments we
were like oh man where were you for the
last 12 months he's like well i was
saying the same [ __ ] behind closed doors
because the in the climate the the
business inc uh climate was not
accepting of this view from somebody
like him but now it is and actually can
i just say that i appreciate that the
conversation has moved from democrats
versus republicans to like let's talk
about business and the economy because i
think that that's what matters it's not
so black and white it's like let's talk
about the actual issues instead of
attacking each other on like political
beliefs yeah the divisiveness there
there's nothing that solves divisiveness
like a crisis
ooh that's a good quote
i mean that's just true
there is nothing that solves
divisiveness like a crisis and usually
unfortunately it used to be people would
go to war
in order to rally the troops there's
people who argue that's what putin is
doing in russia he wanted to rally
support us citizens as it was
fragmenting so he went to war right
war on the pandemic war on inflation now
you're on drugs war on the whole game
that's the whole game it's a marketing
thing of how do you unite people and not
have the divisiveness pick an enemy and
go for it and guess what the enemy is
right now inflation republican democrat
independent genius or idiot
inflation let's solve it but inflation
is something people can rally around
because it directly impacts their lives
just like coven did correct i agree okay
next all right dwyane wade on also
dwyane wade trips me up every time
because i always spell it differently
okay
i had dinner with dwyane wade the other
night no but more importantly he had
dinner with dwyane wade and his wife
gabrielle to be fair there was 12 people
at the table and and we just said what's
up to each other and and uh he was just
far enough where it was a little bit
hard to uh but 15 year old me would have
freaked out if i knew that he was at
dinner with gabrielle union and be like
remember
um step up lebron was there not step up
what is the name
what is this david beckham was there no
i don't care about them i care about
gabrielle union all right all right um
so dwyane wade the husband of gabrielle
uh purchased an equity stake in two
sports teams and he's hosting a tv show
he is also taking a chance with the
volatile nft marketplace what are the uh
sports teams the sports teams what does
it say
uh the uh little
[Laughter]
he took a small stake in nba's utah jazz
in 2021 okay and all these he did this
in the past got it hold on i i know this
i read this utah jazz there's something
about gabrielle
you're stuck on gabrielle union dwyane
wade is a very very savvy business
person and i think that he will continue
to be successful let's go to the next
topic here because we have exactly six
minutes plus four
okay this is plus 90 seconds this is
interesting an upstart financial firm
backed by peter thiel and bill ackman
has a message for american corporations
focus on making money not taking stands
and vivek ramaswamy who made his fortune
in pharmaceutical startups before
writing a book last year called woke inc
says he has raised 20 million dollars to
start a fund manager that would urge
companies not to basically talk about
politics
do we really need a startup to tell us
to tell is it a fund or is it a startup
is it a company or a fund
maybe it's both yeah it's it's a fun
manager but i think it's a company okay
let's just say that it's a fund manager
right uh
if it is a actually i think i believe
what it is is it's a startup asset
manager uh from what i know headline
okay so
this is actually one of the best ways to
get companies to stop the nonsense how
by couldn't being a consultant no by
showing up and saying i have money if
you don't do what i say you don't get my
money
it's activism that's all it is it's just
it's no different than if somebody says
uh like when um elon musk took a
position in twitter everyone's like oh
[ __ ] he's gonna start doing it like he
owns nine percent of the business he now
has a seat at the table he bought his
seat at the table and he now can uh be
an activist bill ackman carl icahn who
don't like each other all these folks
like that's what they do is they put
money into a company and then they go to
work and they try to uh um uh
get them to do things in a certain way
maybe hey you should break up your
business sell off a part of it and maybe
you should go on do mergers and
acquisitions and maybe hey actually we
want to divest from our fossil fuel
energy usage whatever that means right
all these different things but what
these guys are saying is we're gonna
give you money we're gonna tell you shut
up and build your company
stop trying to take stances and all this
crazy stuff right well yeah because
nobody i mean well some people do care i
personally like
if you were to stop shopping at certain
establishments based on the things that
they did i mean you wouldn't shop
anywhere you wouldn't have eat anything
you shouldn't use the internet
wow you should just stop using the
internet well the internet somebody else
uses the internet to do bad things in
the world so you should just get off the
internet so basically what vivec said is
a majority of americans want companies
to stay out of politics they want to
have a separate space for where they
shop where they work and where they
invest from the places where they cast
their ballots or engaged in their
political debates it's so interesting
okay but somebody somebody in the
comments made a good point when you say
that it's a pendulum we're swinging back
baby but when the when he said the
pendulum swings his question was doesn't
that just mean we're going to go to the
other extreme
so the whole point i think is you're
getting way more centrist now who say
listen this pendulum swung too far to
the extreme we need to swing it back but
actually most of the people who are
trying to uh to kind of get back they're
just saying listen
just
build your company don't be extreme left
don't be extreme right actually don't be
left or right just build your company
that's it
they're actually trying to uh get people
to focus on the center yeah all right
next okay what do you think moon plants
is about moon plants uh could it be the
alien door that they found on mars wait
what we'll talk about that tomorrow you
obviously you don't read the news moon
plants plants on the moon
kind of so for the first time ever
scientists have grown plants and lunar
soil returned from the apollo missions
which means that
like what is it i saw matt damon do that
in the martian like six years ago yeah
but that you know that was on mars first
of all but anyway they they wrote um a
terrestrial life can potentially live on
the moon and for astronauts spending any
time on the moon plants can be used for
life support in ways that will that have
only been speculated about it's not so
cool i like it like you can grow plants
on the moon
okay next
it's asked lunch money time so i didn't
have a question what god i'm just i'm
just messing with you don't mess with me
come on i didn't have a question in the
comments you guys go to the video of
lunch money and in the comments do
hashtag asklm and give me a question so
i asked the people in the chat if they
had any live questions and cryptopip
asked how's ranger
uh well you tell me how ranger ranger's
fantastic ranger used to owe me money
but we're cool now ranger is like
outliving his best gentleman true he
runs he runs around in the grass uh in
miami he loves the sun he don't like
other dogs but that that's a whole other
thing uh and uh he chases tennis balls
he loves a good tennis ball loves a good
tennis ball loves a little grass roll
around get your back scratched you know
in the grass it's great sun out you know
ranger out like it's just good to go
life is good yeah yep anything else okay
hold on
yeah
oh oh
western rise product update matt with
the product update hey i'm just saying
evolution pant a.t pant street belt
y'all see the hand in the pocket i told
you i got the street belt on right there
that is hilarious street belt
street belts is probably one of the
single greatest inventions i ever had in
my life for the record for the i
invented that for those of you who don't
know that tie is famous that thai has
been on cnbc during bear markets during
bull markets during regular cow markets
it's been
everywhere
okay politics